The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Basically,
the goal for today--
we're going to sort of
go through the case study
that we had to do just
as a basic framing tool,
and then talk about what it
means to do a corporate carbon
footprint.
What are the mechanisms of it?
What are the issues
that you run into?
And really the
goal of it is this.
One, understand.
It's a pretty simple process,
in terms of there's not much
complexity or theoretical
complexity to it.
In practice, it's
much more a matter
of data gathering,
decisions, talking
with your marketing
communications people-- things
like that.
But just to get the
mechanics of what
goes into a corporate
carbon footprint down
and how you might use
it to identify where
the emissions are
in your company,
probably the more important
things are this, right?
Understand the
measurement approach.
What is a corporate
carbon footprint?
How does it compare
to other things,
like a supply chain carbon
footprint or a product carbon
footprint, and how
do they go together?
And the other one
is to understand
what this means, since
most big companies do
release their greenhouse
gas emissions, right?
But as we go through
this stuff, we
will see that there's a lot of
discretion that goes into what
exactly they do with that.
So the goal would hopefully
be that, as you go out,
as you're working on
your class project.
Or as you start seeing companies
doing press releases or things
about how they cut x amount
of emissions or whatnot,
understand what went into
that and be able to challenge
whether they're really
making much of contribution
or what goes into that.
So that's sort of
what we're hoping
to get out of today's lecture.
And at the end, we'll
probably wrap up
by talking about how this
relates to next class, which
will be about life cycle
assessment, which is going
to be about a more
detailed methodology
for doing product-level
comparisons.
So what I want to
do first is just
take maybe 10 or 15 minutes here
and just sort of recap the case
study and go over the basics.
And then I'm going
to have you get
into groups and sort of
small groups to discuss
and come together as a consensus
about what your approach is
going to be in terms of
what you're including
and what you're not
in the calculations.
Partly just because
just to make sure
we've all arrived at sort of
the same general conclusions
about how this works,
I did look through most
of what you submitted, though.
Most of it's not too trouble.
There's usually a few things
that sometimes trip people up.
So I'll go over what those
are so you'll have a chance
to sort of-- in your groups, you
can revise or make some changes
if that's the case.
So again, what
we're looking at--
we're putting you in
the shoes of WidgetCo.
Essentially you are
a chair manufacturer
selling office-type chairs,
where you manufacture them.
You own your own manufacturing.
You sell primarily to
customers in the US,
both at the retail level
and to industrial consumers.
Facilities-wise, you have
two manufacturing plants.
One is located in Shanghai.
The one is located
here in US in Michigan.
The one in Michigan
is fully owned.
The one in China as
a 50-50 joint venture
with local investors.
You have two
distributions centers
in the US-- one in
California and one in Georgia
that you use for finished goods.
And you also have a partnership
with a large retailer that
sets aside some dedicated
space within each
of their large big box retailers
dedicated to just showcasing
your products.
Transportation.
You use a 3PL to bring in
imported materials and finished
goods.
So you have the
raw materials that
come in by ocean that get sent
to your factory in Michigan.
You also have
finished chairs coming
in from the plant in China.
Those come in over a dedicated
3PL by ocean to get to the US
and then by rail and by
truck once they arrive.
For the retail channel,
you service that primarily
with your private truck fleet.
So you own a fleet
of trucks that you
use to deliver to retailers.
And then you make
up for the rest
of the volume that
you can't handle,
either by air or by lessened
truckload shipments.
And finally, for the
industrial channel,
most of your customers, they
actually come and pick it up.
So you don't handle
that transportation.
The remaining 40% are
done by deliveries.
I think it was by LTL.
So that's basically
what we have here,
is sort of the
supply chain flow.
Most of your suppliers
are located off in China.
That's where your raw materials
and parts of coming to,
shipping it out to your plants
in Michigan and Shanghai.
Again, this in channel,
all this goes on in the US.
And just if we look at
it in terms of this flow,
this is sort of where our
transportation has come in.
So pretty straightforward and
simplified example of a supply
chain.
And the goal is to go
through and figure out
what your carbon footprint is
based on a couple of things,
right?
You're getting pressure
from investors.
You're getting it maybe
from some of your customers
asking about it.
So now it's starting
to get some attention
within the organization,
from the CEO.
And basically you're
the one put in charge
of figuring out what that is.
The pressure's sort
of ratcheting up.
So FerretCo is basically
your main direct competitor.
They operated a little
bit lower price point.
But they're starting
to try to increase
their profile by doing some of
the sustainability initiatives.
So part of that is they want
to move into the retail space,
whereas previously
they've mainly
served industrial companies.
So as part of that, they've
released their carbon footprint
publicly disclosed in the
carbon Disclosure Project.
And that came out at
55,000 tons of CO2.
Based on their sales
and their product,
that was 1.1
kilograms per product.
So that's aggregate emissions.
And this is sort of a
per-product or per-unit level.
They've also announced
a plan that they're
going to become carbon neutral.
And also they're exploring
putting a carbon label
on their retail products.
A new entry into
the market-- they're
trying to appeal directly
to the end consumers
that they'll be
trying to sell to.
So with that in place, if
we look at the supply chain,
we have a number of different
emission sources, right?
We have all these different
transportation pieces
that are linking
these different flows
that we have some data for.
We have emissions
coming from our plants,
in terms of electricity
and direct emissions.
So obviously you're
consuming electricity
that generated emissions of
PowerPoint when it was created.
You also might have
some direct emissions.
We don't specify where
that's coming from,
but you might be burning
natural gas or fuel
oil in the facilities.
Other types of
manufacturing processes--
might release
chemicals directly,
especially in chemicals.
Agricultural companies, right?
They produce other types
of direct admissions.
But we'll just leave it as
direct emissions in this case.
You also have some of
these different facilities
that are consuming electricity.
So if your DCs and also
what's going on at-- you
have those dedicated little
show rooms in big depot.
So this is essentially
the calculation
set up that we gave you.
I do want to go over
just two quickly.
So first, facility is pretty
straightforward-- electricity
consumption times
the emissions factor.
This is in general how basically
every calculation goes, right?
You have these
emissions factors that
are published by organizations
like the Greenhouse Gas
Protocol that are going to tell
you what the emissions are--
four different factors.
So different fuel types
and different electricity
consumptions, where
they're going.
How much do they emit?
And then basically it's
your job to gather data
about how much you consumed
or how much of that material
you used, a factor in
the direct emissions.
For some of these other
things, when that data is not
available-- especially if this
is the case in transportation--
you might have a choice of
several different methods.
So in this case, we had
two different ones-- one
based on ton-miles and one
based on fuel consumption.
So this would generally be
the preferred choice-- fuel
consumption-- mainly
because it's simple.
If you know how
much fuel consumed,
you know the
emissions factor, you
know how much
emissions it produce.
And in cases like
diesel or gasoline,
the CO2 emissions are
pretty much directly tied.
It's basically a one-to-one
correspondence in terms of,
every gallon of fuel you
consume is going to produce
a set amount of emissions.
It's not going to
change too much.
So you'd like to get to
that fuel consumption.
But that's not always
easy to get, especially
when you're hiring a
third-party carrier
or, more importantly,
when you're using
shared transportation assets.
So on a dedicated
transportation,
I hire a truckload company.
They come up, they put
my goods on the truck,
and they take it someplace.
It's nothing but
my goods on there.
So all of the emissions that
are generated when that truck is
going would be dedicated to me.
So I can just try to
maybe make an estimate
of the fuel consumed and get
how much the emissions would be.
When you're looking
at rail or ocean,
where an ocean ship
might have thousands
of different containers
on it and maybe
only one or two of
those are your goods,
you're not really
interested in how much
the total ship or the total
rail car might have emitted.
You want to know how much is
essentially dedicated to you.
So in this case, usually
what we do is that.
We would measure the
efficiency of the vehicles
in terms of how much
fuel they consume
or emissions they all
put per ton-mile, right?
So a ton-mile is a
pretty common indicator
in the transportation, right?
And that's just 1
ton times 1 mile.
If you move one ton of goods
one mile, that's one ton-mile.
So you can think about it.
If you have 20 tons on there and
you go one mile, 20 ton-miles.
So if you had one
ton and you took it
20 miles, also 20 ton-miles.
The reason we would
do it like this
is because generally those
larger vehicles-- the larger
the ocean ship goes, the
more fuel it consumes, say,
per kilometer that it moves.
But as it's starting
to aggregate,
it carries more and
more goods on it.
So it's actually becoming
more efficient in terms
of the actual goods
that it moves,
because it can move
a lot more product
that same amount of distance
on a less amount of fuel.
So lower fuel consumption.
The trick with this--
and this is something
that tripped a few
of you up on it--
is when you have
aggregated data, right?
So if you look at
the data that we had,
we don't have a breakdown
of every single shipment,
especially when you're a company
that's maybe making thousands
and thousands of shipments.
You may not have a direct
record of every single shipment
that you send, in terms of its
distance and its total tonnage.
So what you might
get is something
like what we gave you.
Say you knew that you had--
let's do a quick example.
Say we just add two shipments.
That's all we sent.
And the first one, I had 10 tons
on it and I sent it 10 miles.
So pretty simple.
That's 100 ton-miles.
The second one,
we have five times
and we send up five miles.
That's 25 ton-miles.
So in total, I moved 125
ton-miles' worth of goods.
The trick is this, is that if
we were to aggregate this--
and this is what you are
given in the exercise.
You know something like,
you sent two shipments.
And you moved a total 15 tons.
And you moved a total
of 15 miles, right?
The problem is that
if you try to take
these aggregated numbers and
just multiply them together--
15 times 15.
It's 225, right?
It's very different from
what you actually did.
And this goes back to our--
If we go all the way
back to, I don't know,
our junior high math, right?
A times B plus C times
D. That does not equal--
Right.
So I can't add these two and
add these two and multiply them.
You just get a different number.
So if you just
take the aggregate
you did, especially when
we had 1,000 shipments.
So you moved 26 million
miles or whatever it was,
and you moved 50
million kilograms
and just multiplied
them together.
You got some really huge number.
And it probably threw
off the calculations.
You ended up having, say,
your ocean transportation
or something being by far the
largest source of emissions.
So that's just one
thing to look out for.
When we've done this--
we've given this in the past
with the executive
ed participants.
And 99% of them always
do the same thing.
So I knew that would
possibly trip you up.
But I think in the
examples that we gave,
we broke it out is that
one way to get around
this would be to assume it
went the average distance
and the average weight,
and then multiply those
together, and then multiply
it by the number of shipments.
It won't be exact,
but it'll be closer,
because if you just add them
up and then multiply them,
you're going to be off
by orders of magnitude.
So in terms of the calculations,
that was just one of the things
I saw that that is
tricky to look out for.
The emissions factor.
So we only gave you
a limited set here.
But if you go out and look at
the greenhouse gas protocol,
there will be an emissions
factor for basically every type
of fuel.
So you'll have coal, natural
gas, fuel oil, diesel,
gasoline-- all
different sort of ones.
So even though we
just basically did
electricity and
diesel in here, there
are a whole host
of other factors.
So if you have a
company that's consuming
different types of energy,
the same principle applies.
You know how many cubic feet
of natural gas you consumed,
and you know its factor.
For most companies,
you're not going
to really need much more than
this to do the calculations,
because most companies
aren't doing much
other than either burning fuel,
either in furnaces or bunkers
or in vehicles or
consuming electricity.
They do make some
specialized calculators
for different sectors-- cement
manufacturing, certain chemical
production, paper pulp.
Things that actually
produce emissions
through, say, different
chemical processes that are not
going to be covered by that.
But for the most part, most
companies and most facilities
are just going to be able
to be done by these pretty
simple calculations.
And just in terms of the actual
underlying mechanics of this.
So most of the time, when
we're talking about a carbon
footprint, we're talking about
the six gases that are usually
known as the Kyoto gases.
These are the six gases that
were covered under the Kyoto
Protocol.
Carbon dioxide, especially
in transportation and fuel
consumption, is by far
the largest contributor.
They usually also produce
perhaps a little bit
of methane, nitrous oxide.
And other processes might
produce HFCs, PFCs, sulfur
hexafluoride.
There are other gases that
contribute to global warming,
other greenhouse gases.
But they're not necessarily
covered under Kyoto.
So this is just something
to look out for,
especially refrigerants
and some of the others
that were covered under
the ozone, the Montreal
Protocol, which covered ozone.
Since they were already
being regulated,
they weren't included
in the Kyoto Protocol.
So a lot of things, especially
like the greenhouse gas
protocol, don't require
you to measure those.
But you can measure those
and report them separately,
because they do contribute to
the overall greenhouse effect.
Our emissions
factors are usually
represented in a single unit,
carbon dioxide equivalence.
Essentially we're trying
to measure different gases,
contribute to global warming
and different amounts,
based on how much radiative
forcing they cause.
So essentially, every
kilogram of methane,
say, contributes, say, as much
global warming as 34 kilograms
of carbon dioxide.
So essentially what
would happen is
that every kilogram of
methane you would multiply
by its global warming
potential to determine
how much carbon dioxide
that would be equivalent to.
And so all of these
factors that we give
are in terms of carbon
dioxide equivalence.
So they're incorporating the
amount of methane and nitrous
oxide that might be
emitted in there as well.
Part of this is that
these constantly
get updated-- or not
constantly, but occasionally
updated as part of
the IPCC process.
So they actually just
released in 2013,
I think, the fifth
version of this.
And so some of these
factors have changed.
So that's something
to keep track
of, especially for a company
that's doing it long term.
Those factors can
change as you go,
which sometimes means you need
to go back and recalculate
and figure it.
And one thing to be careful
for is that people typically
refer to things as
carbon footprint
or the amount of
carbon they're doing.
Sometimes when they
say that, they actually
mean just the carbon dioxide.
Most the time it includes
all of these gases.
But you should be careful
and look out for that,
and make sure you're
stating that upfront
when you're doing
this sort of thing,
whether you included all of
these or just carbon dioxide.
The other thing we asked in
here was the emission scopes.
So this is actually
pretty straightforward.
Once you think about
what is included
in your organizational
boundary and whatnot,
scope one is direct
emissions, right?
They're direct because
you could put a CO2
to monitor and
actually monitor it,
because they're directly
coming from your facility,
either from your burning
fuels usually or from one
of those chemical processes.
So they're the
emissions that are
coming from the
vehicles you own--
they're yours-- or
within your facilities,
directly coming at those
facilities, usually basically
through fossil fuel combustion.
Scope two are the
indirect emissions
that come from electricity.
So your facility is
consuming electricity.
Those emissions are
actually occurring
at the power plant, where
they're burning the coal
to supply that electricity.
So we report that
as a separate scope,
because most companies
and most buildings
are making use of electricity.
So usually this falls into sort
of the basic minimum carbon
footprint that we would consider
for an organization-- scope
one and scope two.
Scope three is all the other
indirect emissions, right?
So one thing to remember is
that all these emissions are
somebody's direct emissions.
But they may not
necessarily be what you're
consider your organization.
So anything that's not in
your scope one or scope two
is going to be scope three,
probably because it's
somebody else's scope one.
So when you're going
through and thinking
about what's in your
organizational boundary, what
you've decided as part of your
carbon footprint-- scope one,
emissions you're
directly producing;
scope two, the ones
that are coming
from electricity
that you consume;
and basically everything
else is scope three.
AUDIENCE: For transportation,
if I owned a fleet,
would that be scope one?
And if I hire someone to move
it, would that be scope three?
I'm not really sure
how that works.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
In general, these
are going to be
things that occur directly owned
by you or in your-- sometimes
you may not own it.
But if you have direct
control over it,
especially like some
facilities where
you have a long-term lease or
if you have a arrangement where
you put down a long term
for hire with a carrier,
they still might be scope
one even if you didn't do it.
It's Based on what
you defined as
your organizational boundary.
So scope one and scope two
are things that you basically
have to report, because
you directly admitted
them or they have electricity.
Scope three are
things that you might
want to consider within your
carbon footprint boundary
but aren't directly owned
or within your organization.
AUDIENCE: Generally
emissions from the usage
would not be
considered [INAUDIBLE]
for the purpose of this?
PROFESSOR: Of the
products that you produce?
Yeah.
Yes, so we'll talk about
this a little bit later.
Scope three is anything that's
not scope one and scope two.
And you may be
mandated on a minimum
that you need to include.
But usually there's
no regulation
that says you can't include
something in your boundary.
So you could include those
within your company's boundary.
But if it's a product you're
selling to a consumer,
that would fall under
scope three of indirect.
And we'll talk a little
bit more about this
at the end when we
go through this.
Again, so the case study,
basically go through.
We sort of listed
all the activities
in the spreadsheet, asked
you to go through, identify
the emission factor, and
identify the activity driver.
So how much you
consumed of that.
How much you wanted to include
in your company's carbon
footprint, anywhere
from 0 to 100.
So if you were
excluding it, zero.
And then if you
are including it,
you'd have to give some
percentage for that and why.
And identify whether they're
scope one, scope two, or scope
three emissions.
Decide whether you're
going to disclose this,
and what you're including.
And also, given what
FerretCo's doing,
how do you feel about pledging
to become carbon neutral
or labeling your products?
So we've already
gone through it.
Hopefully you all
did originally.
But I want to give
you a few minutes
now just to sit in small
groups and talk it through.
And then we'll
use that as a-- so
you'll have a chance to go
back through the calculations
and settle on as a
small group one number
that we'll use as the
discussion within your group.
So you can go back throughout.
We've talked it
through and revised
any of the calculations or the
scope, if you need to do that.
So let's just
separate into small--
I don't know-- three,
four, two, whatever.
Just get together.
So you have somebody
else to go over it with.
Hopefully each group
has a computer with them
that they can pull up
the spreadsheet on.
And let's just take-- I don't
know-- 10 minutes, 15 minutes,
or whatever and go through
and come up with those.
And then we'll sort of
run through all of this.
So the first question we have
is, what is WidgetCo's carbon
footprint.
So why don't we go through.
And tell me how many times
you said WidgetCo's carbon
footprint was.
How many thousand tons.
AUDIENCE: The total
aggregate carbon footprint?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: 393.
PROFESSOR: 393.
Yeah, a thousand tons.
AUDIENCE: 395.
PROFESSOR: Others?
AUDIENCE: We had two different
[INAUDIBLE]-- 399 and--
AUDIENCE: I725.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: 378.
PROFESSOR: 378?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: 680 was the other?
AUDIENCE: 650.
PROFESSOR: 650.
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Do I need
to do something?
Hello?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, we hear you.
AUDIENCE: 305.
PROFESSOR: 305?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So I went through it earlier and
compiled the individual answers
from the people
that had submitted.
So here's what they look like.
So we had a couple outliers,
because this is basically
just a calculator.
And they're in the calculation
overestimating the ton-mile
or something like that.
So if we bring it down to
scale or something like this.
Most of you answered
in that range
that we talked
about-- 300 to 400.
Some high or some less.
We can see where did
those emissions come from.
I went through and pulled
out a few possibilities.
The highest level-- if
we included everything
on that list, right?
100% of the emissions
for everything
that was on that list.
That would be essentially
our supply chain emissions
for this portion of
the supply chain.
That comes out to about
$580,000 tons, right?
So on a per kilogram of product
basis, that's about 6.93.
So that should be probably be
the upper end of the range,
because that's
including everything
that we had in there.
You might have made some
different assumptions
in how we calculated
some of these things.
So that's probably why
some are 395 and 399.
Things like that can
make them smaller.
Differences in there.
The real question,
though, comes to be--
I mean, the main thing is, how
much of that Shanghai operation
are we considering?
So if we look at the
supply chain emissions,
we have the
manufacturing in the US.
And most of you-- everybody
was pretty consistent on that.
Straightforward once you
make the calculation.
We pretty much have
to include that.
We own that.
It's all scope one or
scope two emissions.
The plant in China--
same deal, right?
Scope one or scope two, if
we've included in the boundary.
But we can make
some different calls
based on what sort of
organizational boundary we
want to set.
And so if you look at it in the
greenhouse gas protocol-- so
as one of the standards and
probably the most popular
standard.
It basically outlines
two different approaches
you can take.
One is an equity
share approach, right?
So you say, well, how
much of this do I own?
And I'll calculate
the whole emissions.
And then I own
50% of that plant,
so I'm going to take
50% of those emissions.
So if we were to do the
equity share approach,
those emissions from the China
plant get cut in half, right?
And so I get a lower, right?
The important thing
to remember about this
is that, at the
corporate level, it
was mentioned earlier, right?
It's accounting,
as you guys say.
And if you look at the
greenhouse gas protocol,
it's a corporate accounting
and reporting standard.
Nothing changes in
terms of the supply
chain or the actual operations,
the actual emissions
that were out there, right?
We're just changing
how much of them
we're going to take
responsibility for
or how much we're going
to include in our own.
So that's the equity
share, which is basically,
anything that I own
a percentage of,
I take that percentage
of emissions.
And so all the things
that I own are 100%.
And actually it can
go down even more
if we want to
exclude all of the--
there's all these scope
three activities out
there as well that I
don't actually own those,
so I can exclude those as well.
The other approach is what they
refer to as a control approach.
And they can do financial
or operational control.
So this, we would probably
need to know a little bit more
about what's going
on at that plant
to decide what the right
approach was, because it could
easily be, I'll take
100% of those emissions
or I'll take 0%, depending
on who's actually
running the plant
and who's actually
making all of those
decisions, who ultimately
have responsibility
for everything that's
going on in there.
If I've just invested in it
and my partner-- I've invested
and I've done a joint
venture, because they have
all of the local knowledge.
They're the ones
with the expertise.
They're basically
running the plant
and making all the decisions.
And I'm doing an
operational control.
Then maybe I say I have 0%.
And so I might throw that out
of my emissions in my company.
Most likely, if it's
a 50-50 joint venture,
supplying directly to you, you
have some operational control
over that, right?
They're manufacturing your
product almost exclusively.
So even then, you
might say, even
though it's a 50-50
joint venture,
I'll go ahead and
take 100% control.
You don't really have
much of a decision
other than 0, 50, or
100 on this, right?
The emissions that are there,
you either account for them
or you don't.
That is, they're in your
boundary or they're not.
And so that's a 0% or 100% on
the operational control side.
And on the equity share, it's
basically just decided 50-50.
So you don't get to
really hedge and say,
well, I'm only going to take
a third of these emissions
or something like that.
At the lowest level, we could
do something like-- just
my corporate emissions,
which is just
going to say, this would be
what you would get if you said,
I'm only going to
include things I directly
own-- 100% ownership for.
So that's going to be
just my Michigan plant.
Adjust my distribution centers.
Adjust my private fleet.
Those are the things that I
own, I have direct control over.
I'm only going to include those.
If you did that,
you'll get something
just a bit over
200,000 tons on that.
So one of the other
things is that, when
we look at all those
different scope
three activities that
we had, especially
with the transportation--
I had the LTL.
You have the air, the long
haul, the short hall, the ocean.
Usually that's going to
be the same case, where
the decision is going to be
whether I include that or not.
And once you do, then you
need to account for 100%.
You're saying, do I have
some operational control,
or is this fitting
within what I consider
my company's boundaries?
In which case, I'm going
to account for them.
And when I've decided
to account for them,
you have to sort of go
ahead and take all of them.
They don't contribute a whole
lot to the overall carbon
footprints.
So a lot of times, you
may spend a lot of time
making these sort
of decisions that
turn out to be a pretty
small case overall.
For some companies, it can
be a pretty large share
of their emissions.
And this is generally for the
transportation and distribution
environment.
We'll talk about all
the other scope three.
AUDIENCE: My question's
about not putting it
in between percentages.
Couldn't it be OK to put,
I don't know, a 10% or 15%
just to pressure the company
into starting relationships
with your suppliers and trying
to talk over these topics.
If not, there's no pressure,
and you're just like, OK,
it's fine.
I don't care.
PROFESSOR: So it's almost
two separate issues, right?
Whether do we want to account
for the-- you're my supplier.
You provide
transportation service.
Do I want to account
for your emissions
within my corporate
carbon footprint,
within my organization boundary?
And that's a yes or no
decision in that sense.
I should include these.
Especially for the
transportation,
when we talk about
operational control,
that's very hard to separate.
If you're a carrier that
I have a contract with
and I'm telling you, take this
truckload of goods from point A
to point B, it's your
truck and your driver.
But I'm the one that's
made that decision
to send those truckloads.
So a lot of
companies-- we'll see
in a bit about what
percentage of companies
start to account for
these different things.
But a lot of
companies would feel
that that's their emissions,
especially when it's
going from my factory to my
DC or something like that.
I would maybe consider
that part of my selection.
So that's generally yes or
no-- I'm going to include these
or I'm not.
And if I'm going
to include them,
then you usually
are going to include
100%, because part
of this is that it's
trying to be a standard.
So it's trying to apply a
certain set of principles
and have companies
follow it, because
while different companies
may make different decisions
about what they include
or not, you start
getting into a really gray
area when you start saying,
well, I'm including
these, but I'm only
going to include 8%, 15%, 25%.
So as to the answer of
which is the correct one,
there really isn't one.
So if we look
through what it means
to do the corporate
carbon footprint,
it typically starts
with defining
your organizational
boundary or what method
you're going to
use to define that.
And once you've done that, it
all starts to flow from that.
And there's usually a
minimum standard slide.
So if you look at the greenhouse
gas protocol, they say,
in order to follow
our standard, you
take this approach
of deciding what
your organizational boundary is.
And then you must account
for the scope one and scope
two emissions, right?
So once you've decided that
organizational boundary, scope
one and scope two, you
have to include it.
The scope three
tend to be optional.
And so it's up to the
company to decide.
And I think most people would
say it's the more scope three
you include the better so
that you're bringing more
into-- more of them become
your responsibility.
You start taking more care about
what you're doing with those.
But there's no
requirement that says you
have to for most scope three.
There's also one
other issue, which
is that for some
regulatory issues,
you may actually even choose
something less than this.
So the California Air Resources
Board has regulations.
There's different regional
greenhouse gas initiatives.
If you're operating
in Europe, you
may have things
where you're required
to report on emissions
that happened in a even
smaller boundary, right?
So California might be just
in the state of California.
Or if you're involved in the
EU Emissions Trading Scheme,
you might have some emissions
that occur just in the EU.
And you might report
even a subset of these
that fall within that boundary.
So there's a lot
of different ways
of how we dice up what the
company's carbon footprint is.
So that's sort of
the first thing
to look for is when a company
starts reporting and starts
making announcements of this.
How much information do they
give about what they included?
And can you start looking
at where those emissions
in the supply chain came from.
AUDIENCE: Change the standard
to make it a little more
uniformed in terms of
people should report on this
to try to make the
numbers make a little
more sense for companies
across a certain industry?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So a couple things.
So one is, it's
basically they're
trying to take
accounting principles
and just apply them to carbon.
And it's hard enough getting
the accounting principles
worked out, which is why you
get all sorts of obscure rules
and different companies making
different choices about what
they include and
where they include it.
So the greenhouse
gas protocol has
taken the approach of a
generic standard that will work
for a lot of different uses.
And what you'll find
is that then you
might have different programs,
that if you want to participate
in this program,
they might specify
certain rules that, say,
you're going to have
to do this or this or this.
So voluntary climate, carbon
exchanges, things like that.
They might decide that you must
take this approach to doing it
and then you must
include these emissions.
So it's more that there are
many different programs.
And the greenhouse gas
protocol is one standard
and sort of more of
a framework perhaps
to think about how we would
go through doing this.
It's the most widely used one.
If you look at, for example,
the Carbon Disclosure Project,
which is collecting all this
information from companies,
they usually ask them
what they're using,
or what approach did
you use to do this.
And it's something like 90-plus
percent of companies that use
the greenhouse gas protocol.
And typically that means scope
one, scope two, scope three.
They specify that they use
operational control equity
share and things like that.
AUDIENCE: So suppose [INAUDIBLE]
scope three or [INAUDIBLE] 25%.
It should be scope one
for the first response.
So we'll [INAUDIBLE]
twice, or is that 25%?
PROFESSOR: So this is where
it gets into different--
so generally, a program
has money at stake, right?
Then a lot of times they're very
concerned with double counting,
so especially when
you reduce things.
So if you're under the Emissions
Trading Scheme or things
like that, you want to make sure
two separate organizations are
not taking credit for, say, the
same reduction or not counting
it twice.
So in that sense, if
you're participating
in a program like
that, it might say--
and this is how most of
the regulatory programs
work-- you only report
scope one emissions.
So they're actually going
after the power companies,
refineries, the main
manufacturing plants,
and not getting down to the
level of individual cares.
It's starting to move that way,
especially as transportation is
added in the EU Trading Scheme.
But that usually then
takes a different approach
to what it means, right?
So you would likely
report specifically
to the EU Trading Scheme based
on their requirements for it.
And what you do as sort of
your own corporate disclosure,
whether in your CSR reports or
something else, it's up to you
to include.
So both of you may be
claiming the same emissions.
But in general, the question
is whether that's a problem
or not.
And if there's no money or
anything changing hands,
there's not a defined
financial payment going on,
it's usually not a problem to
include the double counting,
because you have two companies
taking responsibility for it
and trying to work through this.
But yeah.
So all the emissions at some
point are somebody's scope one.
Somebody burned the fuel or
did whatever to produce it.
OK.
So in terms of the
carbon footprint.
Even with the standards
and things in place,
there's a lot of
discretion about what
a company can include.
The more important
thing is to recognize
how you draw an
organizational boundary
and then sort of what
you have to report,
whether it's through a
program or a standard
or these minimum requirements.
The other thing is-- so
on the emission sources,
because especially when we
get into this idea of that
if you're a program, you have to
report scope one or scope two.
Identifying where
they are is going
to be sort of an important
piece and typically
when you report
admissions, they're
going to ask you to report them
broken out by scope one, scope
two, and scope three.
So if we look at
the supply chain
and these different sources
of emissions in here,
where are the scope one
emissions going to be?
AUDIENCE: Scope
one is going to be
the direct emissions
from both factories
and the emissions from the
trucks that we actually own.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So we're going to have
our private fleet.
We own these trucks, so
the admissions they burn
are direct emissions.
We have the Michigan
plant, which we own.
So those direct emissions are
going to be our scope one.
And then these
would be scope one,
provided we are considering
the Shanghai plant to be part
of our organizational boundary.
If we excluded it, then those
would moved to scope three.
And it may be that if we took
that equity share approach,
50% of them would be
scope one and 50% of them
would be scope three.
So perhaps a little confusing
from the reporting standpoint.
But usually it follows straight
through from the nature
of the activity that's
going on and where
it happens in relation to
my organizational boundary.
So our scope two.
AUDIENCE: The electricity
in the plants as well as
the distribution center?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So are the other source of
electricity we have is that
the retailer, since we
have those big depot.
We have those dedicated
shared spaces.
That's usually not
something that you're
going to have direct control
over, operational control
over and whatnot.
And it's not an equity share
or not a stake in the company.
So that electricity is generally
going to go under the scope
three, which scope three
is everything that's
not scope one and scope two.
So it all pretty much
comes out in the wash
once you've done that.
So the important thing
is to identify what
our scope one and scope two is.
And again, that just comes
straightforward from the nature
of the emissions
and where it falls
within your
organizational boundary.
AUDIENCE: For this, when
would you [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So that's a decision
you would make before you even
started the exercise, would
be to the right thing to do,
right?
Is to decide what the
first step in the process
is, to decide what your
approach is going to be.
AUDIENCE: Just wondering.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so then I
would divide the emissions.
So in your worksheet, it won't
work that way, because I only
gave you one column to do it.
But then I would report
50% of those as scope one,
50% of these as scope
two, and the other 50%
of each as scope three.
So this is what the share of
scope one, scope two, and scope
three emissions look like,
from what people reported.
Some a little thrown off,
because if you miscalculated
it a little bit, then the
ocean shipment or the LTL
might have contributed
a vast majority.
Most of you included some
manner of scope three
in the carbon footprint.
A few at least didn't, right?
So you could.
There's no reason that
you would necessarily
have to include all
of the scope three.
So you could easily
exclude those.
So that's one thing
to keep track of,
is when we look at the
corporate carbon footprint,
scope three is the green.
For most of you, it was pretty
small, because we were only
looking at-- in terms
of that worksheet,
we were only looking at
things like the transportation
and the distribution.
But as we'll talk about in a
minute, that's not necessarily
really be the case in reality.
But in terms of what
we report, that's
what I saw from
what you guys did.
So this is data from the
Carbon Disclosure Project,
where they looked at--
this is from, I think,
the 2014 reports.
So this would have
been companies
that reported their
emissions to the CDP
in 2013 out of the
Financial Times 500.
And it was asking
them percentage
of companies reporting scope
three categories and how much
the emissions were by category.
So this is saying, for
a category like business
travel out of the 500
companies surveyed
or whatever, almost 80% of
them reported the emissions
from business travel in their
carbon footprint estimate.
So you could tell that's
by far the highest.
And some of the things
that drive these
are-- whether you include
it, whether you consider it
really part of your business,
and generally if you're
sending your
employees on travel,
you would consider
those your missions.
That's things that you're doing.
You had control over that.
Even though they flew on
United Airlines or whatever,
it's something that
you had control
of whether to decide
to send them on travel.
So you sort of feel a
responsibility to include that.
That was clearly much
higher than all of the rest.
if you look down into getting
some of these other things,
like investments, end of
life of sold products.
Only 10% maybe of
companies reported that.
And they have some data.
Now, the problem on
this is these bars
are representing how much
the actual emissions were.
So the company's accounted
for their business travel.
But it's basically an
infinitesimal share
of what's included.
Part of this is
driven by how easy
it is to get this
sort of data, right?
Your airline will happily
sell you a carbon credit
when you go to buy it.
Most of them well.
But if you go back, I did a
corporate carbon footprint
with a large retailer.
And they have all of
this information sitting
in their travel database.
So they just dump
it out and say,
here's every flight every
employee took from this city
to that city, how far
it was, et cetera.
So it's very easy to
calculate some of these.
Figuring out what happened
to the end of life
of every single product
you sold, right?
Pretty difficult to track
down and get that information.
So probably explains why
less companies did it.
And then you look at, only
20% percent of companies
reported, say, on the use
of their sold products.
But you saw
magnitude-wise it's more
than basically every
other category added up
on the ones that did include it.
So part of the thing
with scope three
is that it's always sort of
at your discretion of what
to include.
And the decision that
drives it within companies
is not necessarily
how important it
is but a lot of times how easy
it is to get that information.
And also how much
responsibility you feel.
Do you feel that what
happens to the end of life
of your products is
your responsibility?
Or do you consider
that the consumer's,
the one that decides
whether to recycle it
or throw it away or do whatever.
So maybe you decide
that's not emissions
that you want to consider
in your boundary,
because you don't have the
direct control over it.
Whereas employee
travel, that's something
you do have control over.
OK.
Any questions about the scopes?
OK, just to recap some of the
mechanics of carbon footprints,
the first step-- determining
your organizational boundary,
right?
And generally, that
starts with deciding what
approach you're going to take.
And probably you want
to decide that and think
about it ahead of time.
The greenhouse gas
protocol spends a lot
of time talking
about aligning this
with your financial and
accounting reporting.
So it probably makes sense,
especially a large company
publicly traded, that when
you're going to go through it,
it makes sense to go through
and set this up in the same way
that you've got your
accounting system set up
to make that process
a little bit easier.
Once you've got the
organizational boundary set up,
then you need to
start determining
your operational boundary.
So anything that's in your
organizational boundary that's
scope one or scope two of
your operations, that's
the things you're going
to have to include.
But then you need
to identify which
of the scope three emissions
you're going to include.
And generally, the
decision of this
should generally be
separate from the decision
of actually gathering
the data or doing
the emission, in theory.
In practice, they're
related because you
might want to include
something but you
can't get the data on it.
But otherwise, you're
looking at the situation of,
I'm going to measure
the emissions,
and then I'm going to
include all the ones that
are really small.
I'm not going to include
the ones that are big.
So generally you can think of
these as a set of principles
of sort of work down in order.
So you're going to
decide whether something
should be included or not.
Then once you make
that decision,
go out and do the work to gather
the data and calculate it.
And finally, once
you've decided what's in
and what's out, what
you're including, running
out and gathering
the data and getting
the appropriate emissions
factors from it.
So this is usually
the tricky part
of going through and figuring
out all those facilities, all
that transportation, anything
related to the scope three
and getting that
data, because they
tend to come for a lot of
different data sources,
if you think about who knows.
Again, a lot of
times if you've paid
the bill for it--
electricity, fuel,
things like that--
it's pretty easy
to track down a little more.
But as you start
getting into it,
if you wanted to
talk about the waste
that you're generating at your
facilities, the transportation
where you're trying to get.
How far did things go?
What sort of mode did I use?
You have to start
going out to basically
all the different parts
of your organization
to start gathering that
data, because there's usually
not a single repository
where that is.
So the big pain for
a lot of companies
is that it's a very manual
process at this stage,
because you're pulling from
the transportation management
system, your warehouse
data or your facilities.
You're getting from
the facilities manager.
Your procurement
group is the one
that knows what you're buying
and who you're buying it from,
where it's coming from.
And so usually they're going to
dump all that data to an Excel
spreadsheet or an Access
database and something
like that, and somebody
in your organization
is going to get stuck
with the responsibility
for taking all of
that, translating it
into the calculations.
If you look at the
GHC protocol, they
have a bunch of
calculation tools.
They're just spreadsheets.
So it's still a very manual
process at this stage.
Big ERP vendors and things
like that will happily
include some of this carbon
calculation in there.
So there's a move to try to
get some of this automated.
But that's one of the
big barriers right now,
is that it usually
just takes some time
to get it up and get it
running within a company,
to figure out the processes
for how you calculate
the data, what format it comes
in, who does the calculation,
and how you report
it, et cetera.
So as part of that data,
integrity is a big issue,
because you have different
people that don't necessarily
know the overall picture,
calculating, pulling the data
for their bit, sending it in.
The biggest problem I
run into in doing these
are missing values.
So you go to one of your
distribution centers,
and they come back
with a report that
said they used electricity, fuel
oil, natural gas, refrigerants,
all of this.
Your other facility
comes back and says,
here's our electricity bills.
Are they missing
all of this data,
or did they really just
not use any of that.
So making sure the data
you're getting is complete.
Aggregation issues, right?
So we saw this.
I'll look through
your spreadsheets
a little bit at greater detail.
But when I went through
it and did this--
so if we look at the data
that we gave you in this,
we had a bunch of data
about the shipment you sent,
x number of shipments by air.
You knew the average weight
of all the shipments you sent.
But we didn't have it broken
out by specific modes.
So when I did it, I just
used the average weight
of the shipment times
the number of shipments
times the average distance
I had for those modes.
It doesn't make sense that my
average air shipment is going
to be 11,000 kilograms and that
my average truckload shipment
was going to be that.
Probably sending my air
shipments by a few hundred
kilograms at a
time, I'm probably
sending the truckload right
by that 20 tons or so.
So once you've got
the data, figuring out
what you can do with it, how
you get it out in the right way,
to sort of separate it
out can be an issue.
Making sure you come up with
appropriate approximations.
And finally, finding the
right emissions factors.
One of the big things--
pay attention to units.
Everybody will report
back in different numbers,
especially if you're
a global company.
You're going to get
natural gas back
in therms, cubic feet, cubic
meters, joules, whatever.
So figuring out the units
that everybody's using
and make sure that you convert
those to the appropriate way.
And apply a consistent
set of emissions factors.
Especially on things
like electricity,
you're going to be
able to break it
down by the country
level, regional levels,
by where the grid is.
You can find information at
the state level, even some
at the municipality level.
The question is,
what you don't want
to get caught doing is cherry
picking the right commission's
factors.
So in areas where they
use a lot of nuclear,
I'm going to use
my local factor.
And when I'm in an area that
gets its energy from coal,
I'm going to use my national
factory to sort of keep me
from ever looking too bad.
So those are just some of
the tricks going in with it.
So one thing is absolute
versus relative measures.
All of this carbon
footprint data in this sense
is getting reported at
the aggregate level.
That's what's important on a
national or a global scale,
right?
How much total carbon are we
pumping into the atmosphere?
But for our company, especially
as your business is growing,
you probably want to also have
some kind of relative measure,
like in there, we were just
measuring per kilogram, as
well.
Just to understand, are you
getting more efficient or not?
Because as your business
changes, either growing
or shrinking, that's going to
change your aggregate level
of emissions.
But you may actually be getting
more efficient at the same time
that you're producing more
aggregate levels of emissions.
So you probably want to
have some other measures
that you calculate in
addition to the absolute one.
And expected carbon footprint
will be refined over time.
The main use of these things
is to compare an organization's
year-on-year performance.
So you're picking some
year as a baseline year
and trying to measure how
you're doing from that.
Most companies are going to
set some target that says,
we want to be at 80% of 1994
levels or something like that.
As your organization
changes, as you
make acquisitions, as you sell
off pieces, a lot of times
you're going to have to go back
and restate previous years'
emissions so that you can keep
that consistent baseline going.
As the emissions factors
change over time,
you may have to go back and
revisit old calculations
and things like that.
So just be aware
that, if you're trying
to do this for the goal
of comparing year on year,
expect to occasionally
have to go back
and think about what your
previous year's emissions
actually were in comparison to
what your business looks like.
So that's the main thing about
the organizational carbon
footprint.
But it doesn't really get
into the other big issues,
which is, what do you do
once you have them, right?
So how many of you
would disclose?
So what are the reasons
that you would disclose?
AUDIENCE: That if
you were higher
than your competitor,
the disclosure
to the list itself
is probably more
of a specific group of users
who are consuming that data.
So it's probably not going to
hurt your consumer base, even
if you are a little bit higher
and it probably sets you up
to be maybe a more
transparent organization
in the eyes of the people
who reviewed this data.
So I sort of thought,
well, as long
as you don't have any egregious
numbers in there, that it
probably can only help you.
And the general
public isn't probably
going to see this data anyway.
AUDIENCE: If you
disclose, even if you're
higher than your
competitor, it gives you
an opportunity to win the
Most Improved award over time.
And a lot of these
numbers don't really
mean anything to consumers.
So you're able to do so
much business market.
So if you're able to
have a headline that
says you decreased your carbon
footprint in your products
by x percentage, that could
actually fall apart there.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think not
disclosing would [INAUDIBLE]
worse, because then people might
assume that you're-- though you
might be actually worse than
your competitor, by disposing,
you set it up where you
can defend that and say,
but we're improving and
these are the reasons,
rather than not disclosing,
which they could just assume
you're [INAUDIBLE].
That's why [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
that probably what
the other company
ended up doing is
defining a very limited scope.
So in terms of
comparing the two,
I think it's not a debate
about what the script should be
and how each compare
to the two companies.
So for me, not realizing
the data was even worse,
that means that they'll
give you a paper.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Who
would not disclose?
Is it because
FerretCo was so low?
Most of your submissions
indicated that as the reason.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So it's assumed that
there's so much discretion
applied to the figures.
I just computed that.
It was impossible for an
uninformed person looking
at the numbers to know
what went into the number.
And so to the
uninformed, they might
think that he's comparing apples
to apples, but [INAUDIBLE].
So that's why.
AUDIENCE: I think the
customers' perspective would
be [INAUDIBLE] the
carbon footprint.
So I thought it would be like
[INAUDIBLE] to publish this
just out of the
blue and impossibly,
because the competitor would
have just published theirs.
And I think the company
might not already
be ready to actually
publish them,
because they were not
ready also to take action
on their manufacturing
or operations
to actually reduce this problem.
So I think that I would
have delayed [INAUDIBLE].
I would have delayed
the disclosure.
The time to come
out with a strategy
and figure out what we can
do to reduce to which part
we can reduce and to which
part we can make neutral
make an announcement
that we're moving
on that half and
that [INAUDIBLE]
2015 and to be carbon neutral
in 2020 based on our strategy,
and then move from there.
But I don't think I would have
just put the number of there
without making sure in the
company that what we can do
and making sure that it's
communicating properly.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So if we look at
what's driving this,
the carbon disclosure project
is probably the most widely done
of public disclosure
programs, right?
And so this is data
from the 2012 report,
which is the most
recent one that I
could find this graph for.
So when they started this
in 2003, right there.
This is out of the
top 500 companies
in the world, 500
largest companies.
They were getting less
than a 50% response rate.
And I think they might
have even [INAUDIBLE].
But that's pretty much steadily
grown over time until now.
It's pretty much hovering
around the 80% level
that it's been there for
the last three years.
So most of the big companies
are going ahead and disclosing
the emissions, probably
because this is driven
by institutional investors.
So essentially they get
mutual funds and other people
to sign on to this.
So it's being driven by
investors [INAUDIBLE],
not end consumers.
And you have the
same sort of deal
with that the
business-to-business pressure.
Most companies
somewhere in their CSR
or in their organization
have maybe some requirements
where they're asking
their suppliers
to do this sort of
thing, to report on it.
A lot of them are not
yet penalizing you
if you don't do it.
But they're starting to
ask, and enough people
are starting to ask
that most companies are
starting to respond.
The end consumer, the average
consumer I do not think
is paying much attention to
whether a company has reported
its carbon footprint or not.
And even companies that
don't respond to this
may be disclosing this
information on their websites
or things like that.
And the other thing
is that some of this
depends on when these companies
started thinking about it,
to your point of the
first time you get it,
it may not be the right
time to disclose that.
You might want to
wait a little bit.
One of the companies
that we did this with,
I think we did it with
them back in 2006.
And they didn't start
reporting until 2011.
So, I mean, there's five
years between when they first
did their corporate
carbon footprint
and when they
started answering it.
And actually at the time when
we went and did it for them,
they didn't even know they
were getting this survey.
And so I went and
looked at their--
you can actually track
companies' responses over time
on the CDP, and you
can go back and look.
And for the first
four or five years,
they had a mix of just didn't
respond or declined to respond.
And their VPs of supply
chain, their CSR person,
their communications director,
and marketing-- none of them
even knew that they were getting
this and declining it, right?
So I don't know who
it was going to,
but somebody in the organization
was taking it and throwing it
away.
So part of this comes
down to getting this
within the organization.
Just the process
of starting this
can be useful in terms
of getting the ball
rolling of understanding
where the emissions are
in your organization, how to
respond to these, giving you
time to start thinking about
how you're going to formulate
a response to win, when
the pressure might start
mounting a little bit more.
Because the other thing that
these investors are doing
is sort of pressuring the
SEC to make it a mandated
requirement in the
same way they might
disclose other financial
information or other
of their public
disclosures to start
releasing some of this
information, the mandatory SEC
filing.
So most companies would
prefer to avoid that.
So some of it could be seen
as a bit of risk mitigation
that if you disclose voluntarily
now and enough companies go
along with this, you could avoid
the regulation that comes down
to it.
AUDIENCE: Do you think
there's industries
where there is way more
pressure to answer than ours?
Because my original
interest was doing Amazon.
They don't report it.
And then it was looking for
comparables just in case
to see if I could find a
market leader in e-commerce.
And I found no leaders in
that specific industry.
So I don't know how that is--
PROFESSOR: So this is something
we've talked about informally
on our researcher.
And part of this comes
from looking at-- OK,
so what happens if you
don't respond, right?
So eventually there's
enough buildup of pressure
to get boycotts or
things like that going.
And the ability to withstand
the research on why do companies
give into these sort
of demands tends
to come down to the fact that,
one, it tends to be cheaper
just to do it, right?
You really just need an
intern and some people
to actually take the time
to pull this data together
to do this.
It's not that complicated.
And most big companies
already have a department
that does the sort of thing.
So the transaction
cost essentially
to do this is pretty
low, so they give in.
The other thing
has to do with that
whether you're consumer-facing
and brand-oriented
or not and what your
market position is.
And the stronger your
market position is,
the less you have to
care what people think.
So somebody like
Amazon, Apple, may not
feel that they necessarily
have to do this test.
And again, and
why did I measure?
So one of things
to think about this
is that there's external
and internal reasons
that you might want to do
this measure, the same way
that any accounting
system you might
have an external financial
reporting system.
You might have your
internal managerial systems
that you use for
something different.
So most of this
tends to be to put it
in a CSR report, investors
or customers asking for you.
You might have
regulation to do it.
You might also have some
internal ones to do it.
If you're setting goals
internally in preparation
for eventually
disclosing, you might
want to do this so
you can understand
where the carbon footprint is.
You can set targets.
You can start putting
requirements on your managers.
You can figure
out where this is.
The other thing to remember
is that the boundaries
we use for this don't
have to be the same.
So especially in the
internal business,
you can include
whatever you want
to include in that measurement.
So to help you drive
reductions at your suppliers,
you might have an
internal system
where you grade managers and
your procurement department
of transportation.
In terms of emissions,
that would be scope three.
But at the same
time, you may not
include those in your
external reports.
So again, there's different
uses for the information.
And depending on what
you want to do with it,
you might draw the
boundary in a separate way.
All right.
So the other thing
is that I want
to cover before
I'll wrap up here
is, does it make sense to
compare WidgetCo and FerretCo.
We saw FerretCo
55,000 tons, right?
Very small.
And so the question is, is it
worthwhile to compare companies
that are direct
competitors to each other,
but because of their
operations, they
may be doing
something differently?
So I actually the Ferret
company numbers, actually-- I
made a fake supply chain
with data the same way
I did for the [INAUDIBLE]
from WidgetCo.
They use contract manufacturers,
as opposed to owning
their own manufacturer plants.
And I just assumed that they
have the same efficiency
as your Shanghai plant does.
They produce less, right?
If you look at the numbers,
their revenues are lower.
You sell about 84 million
kilograms of products.
They sold 50 million.
So they don't produce as much,
but their efficiency per unit
was the same here.
I made up of supply chain where
they had a different model,
which is local sales offices
serving industrial consumers,
because they have a
longer supply chain,
because of all their
manufacturing goes on in Asia.
I assume they used
ocean and then rail
and that they had a
network of 40 seas,
a bunch of local sales offices,
and then a local fleet that
did the transportation there.
So I actually figured out
what these numbers would be
and calculated.
And that's where that
55,000 tons came up.
The big issue, though, right?
If we looked at what I would
sort of consider WidgetCo's
boundary and what
most of you did
is that you're basically stuck
reporting on the Michigan
plant and the California
and Georgia, DC,
and your private fleet.
Most of you included some
share of the Shanghai plant.
And as we saw,
the emissions were
being driven by what's going
on at the manufacturing plant.
That was by far the largest
source of emissions.
It was something like 85%
of the entire supply chain
emissions are coming in there.
WidgetCo's using a
contract manufacturer.
So none of this falls within
their scope one and scope two.
They have a similar
distribution operation to you.
I included their
distribution all the way,
their transportation all the way
up to the industrial customers
that they have.
But when we do it this way,
we draw different boundaries
that allows them to
exclude this piece.
Since they don't know
it, they're buying.
They don't even necessarily
have operational control
if they're just doing contracts
with different manufacturers
to do it along the way.
So this is what happens is
that, under these different
definitions of what we might
consider in the supply chain,
we're going to get
different numbers.
And one of the
things to remember
is FerretCo's always going to
have a smaller looking number
just because they
sell less goods.
So I did at sort of the smallest
level, the corporate level,
which is down into that 370,
level 370-some thousand tons.
If WidgetCo does that,
it's 4.51 per unit.
FerretCo's is about
48,000 and 0.95.
This is what I-- saying
I was publicly disclosed,
which I was going to include
the equity share of what goes on
at Shanghai.
FerretCo, that's their
disclosed number.
That includes some
of those scope three,
and that's what I
gave you in the case.
But if we look at
the supply chain,
if we look at this end-to-end
to what it takes rather
than ignore who owns
what, their emissions
are still going to be less.
But on a per unit basis, I
came up with a higher number.
So this is what a lot of
you got to in your write-ups
and discussion.
It is reporting at the
organizational level
makes you look worse
perhaps than FerretCo does,
if we're just disclosing
this carbon footprint.
So when you're going
in and thinking
about that as a
disclosure strategy,
it's obviously something
you want to include.
And in this case,
a lot of companies
tend to want to be
less transparent.
FerretCo might
disclose this number
and then say nothing
about it, knowing
that it's going to be low.
So perhaps transparency is
your friend in this case.
When you disclose
yours, you can say
we include these because we
own this, this, and this.
And then maybe when
somebody looks up FerretCo
and they're trying to figure out
why their emissions are so low
and they say, well, there's
no information available,
then they'll see that as there's
a push for more transparency
and they start having to
disclose perhaps what they're
including and what they're not.
It starts to come to
light a little bit more
that really it's
because they're doing
different things in their
supply chain that you are.
Supply chain is very similar,
a little bit different
in terms of how they sell.
But they're doing essentially
the same activities
for very similar products.
But it can produce a very
different corporate carbon
footprint depending on where
you draw those boundaries.
And this is starting to
get a lot more attention.
So this is data that
Apple released, right?
So they actually have
a lot of good data
about their environmental
impacts on their web page.
But the thing that
they were showing
is that, out of their
total end-to-end everything
from the raw materials
that go into their products
to customer use and
ventral disposal,
Apple only owns 2% of those
emissions at their facilities.
Everything else is outsourced.
They have somebody else
doing the manufacturing.
Somebody else is doing
the transportation.
Somebody else does the
raw materials, et cetera.
And yet, they won the Best
Supply Chain award from Gartner
for the last six years.
So the idea of the supply
chain is no longer the idea
that I'm owning that.
They're managing all
of these activities,
but they aren't
necessarily doing them
in any of their facilities.
So does it make
sense for me to try
to compare Apple against some
of these other companies.
in the computer
space, they might be
competing against, say, Dell.
Or in the phones, they
might deal with Samsung.
Samsung has 240,000 employees,
40 manufacturing sites.
They produce
refrigerators, washing
machines, all of these
things, in addition
to, say, the Galaxy Tab that
you might compare to the iPhone.
So does it really makes sense to
compare these sort of companies
together on the corporate level?
And the answer is
increasingly, no, it doesn't.
And this is not
unusual for a company
to have a pretty low
amount of many emissions
being in their facilities.
These researchers looked
across a wide range
of activities of manufacturers
of goods-- producers
of actual goods by industry.
What percent of their emissions
were scope one and scope two?
And as you can see,
the top of the red line
is where the scope
one and scope two end.
It can vary a bit.
But on average, they
found it at around 25%.
So most companies, even the
ones that are producing goods,
do not own the majority of their
emissions in the supply chain.
And so we're starting to see
expansion of the greenhouse gas
protocol.
They've actually
created new standards.
One is what they call
the value chain approach.
So this is looking at
the entire supply chain,
from raw materials all the way
to product use and disposal,
and looking at it at
the aggregate level.
So this is trying to say,
what are the total emissions
globally for everything
from beginning to end?
And what they've done is they've
identified different categories
and provided some guidance
on how you measure that.
And so companies can
now start to choose
which of these
categories they report.
I think they said only one
company has reported emissions
in all 14 of these
categories of what they have.
So it's an ongoing
process as companies
try to help them include
more and more of this
so that we can start to see.
This carbon Disclosure
Project started
something called the
CDB Supply Chain Report.
It was started by Dell, L'Oreal,
a couple other companies--
Walmart is now part of
it-- where they're actually
surveying their suppliers and
asking them the same questions
that are in the CDP.
And CDP manages it and
helps get those responses.
The big thing to know is that
it started in 2008 with 1,402
suppliers contracted.
It's grown to be
over 5,000 of them.
So more companies are doing this
with more of their suppliers.
One of the big things is that
the more requests a company
gets for this from different
customers of theirs,
the more likely they
are to respond to it.
So as this pressure's
increasing,
starting to see more
companies willing to respond.
And finally, to
set up what we're
going to talk about next time.
There's also a huge
issue in protocol
has started a product standard.
So what separates
a product standard
is that the value chain--
my company produces
many different products.
I'm going to include
everything in the value chain.
For all those, I'm going to
report aggregate emissions.
The product level says, now
I'm going to instead focus.
I'm going to still do this end
to end upstream all the way
down to stream.
But I'm going to focus
on one specific product.
And I'm going to report
it at the product level.
So when we talk about labeling--
would you put out a carbon
footprint of a
product on a label?--
typically this product standard
is the kind of thing you would
need to do.
And that includes
all of the emissions
from beginning to end.
So that includes,
in our example,
we only talked about
the manufacturing,
the distribution.
We didn't get into the raw
materials, the disposal,
all of these things
that go into it.
So these is actually
what we're going
to talk about on Monday when
we talk about life cycle
assessment, which is basically
the methodology for how we go
into this at the product level.
So just as a recap for that, I
posted-- so essentially there,
I posted an actual report that
some colleagues here at MIT
did that looked at
handwriting systems.
They were looking at
that Dyson air blade
to try to figure out whether
it's more environmentally
friendly to do that than
have paper towels or some
of these other things.
So for Monday, we're
asking you to read that.
So it's a little bit dry.
But there's lots of
tables and charts,
so it should go
by fairly quickly.
But it's a pretty good
example of what it takes
to get into the product level.
And we'll use that for a
discussion about life cycle
assessment and what it
means for a company that
wants to do it at this level.
And then next Wednesday,
we have Martin Wolf
from Seventh Generation
to talk about actually
how their company uses life
cycle assessment to make sure
all the products they're selling
are environmentally friendly.
OK.